hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round two of the 2023
Norway chess tournament
this is the Armageddon game between
Anish giri on the white end and Fabiano
caruana
the classical game they played in round
two was a draw that's why they had to
play this Armageddon
the winner of it earns an additional
Half Point towards the tournament
standings
time controls for this game Geary has 10
minutes carwana 7 and there's a one
second increment beginning at move 41.
black has draw odds and this of course
has a significant influence on the
strategies for each side white really
does need to press
for a win
on board
we have a closed cattle and not the most
common way to arrive at the closed
Catalan but here we are
D takes C4 follows
Queen C2
and this baby move A6 preparing a B5
Advance B5 is stopped in this game with
A4
if Queen takes C4 in this position B5
can be played with tempo
and after the queen moves black is able
to get on this long diagonal and try and
tame the best piece in the position
White's Catalan Bishop
play in this position will revolve
around the C5 Square
or really the C5 Pawn break black would
like to get that move in and exchange
his half dead Pawn for a perfectly
healthy Pawn
okay
in this game A6 met with A4 so was it
worth it
black took one step with the idea to
play B5 and B5 is shut down with this
guy going two steps
well with every pawn move there's a
positive and a negative and the negative
here is that B4 is now a whole
okay
black now follows with Bishop D7 he's
trying to get on the diagonal with these
two moves
trying to move the B Pawn in this
position well the B Pawn is you'll know
not advancing in this case with tempo
like the variation with B5 attacking the
queen this would give white time to play
Knight E5 and this is pretty irritating
so goes about it with Bishop D7
Queen takes C4 follows in this game
if the Knight still hops into E5 the
bishop's still gonna go here and we
could have a totally different ball game
ahead totally different structure
okay another path the game could take
in this game it is simply Queen takes C4
Bishop C6 Bishop F4 it's a strong piece
on F4
there's some coordination on C7
it's challenged straight away with
Bishop D6
and white simply follows with Knight C3
capturing the bishop on D6 probably not
a good idea
well I could recapture with the pawn
small Pawn Center open C file this
Queen's probably not feeling so
comfortable there's going to be a
valuable tempo right around the corner
once The Rook is on C8
she's gonna have to move again
he also cut out a key improving move
from the night
okay
so the tension simply remains white
continues to develop allows black to
take on F4 and white is okay he says I'm
okay taking on a somewhat compromised
King side structure this newly opened
G file half open G file I'm going to try
and
use that to my advantage
Okay so
black is on move here throw this to you
as a pop quiz Can you spot what
carwana's next move is move 12 feel free
to pause the video
okay no crazy tactics here this is more
of a positional test
his move is
A5
doing what
guarding the B4 square with a pawn
it's a hole and now there's a pawn
controlling that square
okay
next up we have E3
there is a central majority that white
has two to one
but
to try and
let's say Advance this Central majority
and that wouldn't be a good idea
frequently it is a good idea when you
have a majority you set it in motion
but trying to get in some move like E4
would not be a good choice because that
would leave this square right here
and it would become a hole and right
around the corner you could see a knight
getting there
that would be a disaster for white
so it's one of those proceed with
caution don't try and just see it as I
have a majority let's push it to
recognize the big gap the big weakness
that would be created in playing E4
so it's the more solid here
E3 controls the center points F4
F4 and D4
from here
can you guess what Black's next move is
move 13.
here we go
Knight A6 see what's happening here do
you see the progression that's happening
with these last handful of moves from
move seven
we're at move 13 now
white goes with H3
cuts out any night jump
it's looking at King H2
Knight B4 so
how did we get here how did this night
get to B4
it dates all the way back to move seven
with that baby move A6
A6 did what provoked a weakness on B4
what's the next step
control that hole with the pawn
got it with the pawn on A5 final step
put a piece there and the piece is going
to love you
because it can't be scared away there's
no white pawns that could scare the
night away and who knows maybe a fork is
right around the corner if white isn't
careful
all right this is a strong post for the
Black Knight
from here King H2
G6 black is already anticipating White's
idea White's plan here to do something
in the G file so this is a strong point
now on G6 there's also a square for the
king if he needs it
all right G6 on board Rook G1 I like the
timing here this was instructive for me
to see this Rook G1 is played notice
this guy is not yet moving
until
this guy's on G1 why is that
King E7 Knight G5
What's Happening Here
well after Bishop takes Bishop The Rook
is the one that gets to recapture and
now this square is immediately opened up
for the doubling of the Rooks on the G
file
so if if white was moving this night
before
this Rook was on G1 we'd have Bishop
takes and the king would have to be
recapturing and the King doesn't want to
be on this G file
okay also this night move I should
mention the Knight going to G5 rather
than E5 it has an idea his idea is to
remove this King side Defender a knight
on F6 is a fantastic Defender for the
king side
so he has an eye on Knight E4 and the
knight from E4 also watches out for the
C5 Pawn break
all right from here we have Rook C8
black is trying to get this break in
what other way is there
for black to try and open up a line for
the Rooks
okay it's not going to be E5 for as long
as these two are around maybe E5 later
if
black can get rid of this Pawn though
but for right now there's a huge grip
over E5 first things first Rook C8 prep
work
for C5 this is really a battle of ideas
Battle of plans this Armageddon game
Knight E4
B6
more prep work
for C5 and now incomes ripped to G5
computers not a big fan of this
particular move it's designed to
watch out for this C5 Pawn break
as it turns out this isn't actually
stopping C5
um I should mention the Rook on G5
you know what move would white like to
see in this position a move like H6
a move like H6 would weaken G6 and make
the ID of H4 H5 that much more effective
so
my point here if you're playing is black
don't be too tempted to try and kick
this Rook off of this file probably
better to stay strong on G6 and
anticipate this
serious pressure on the G file with the
Rooks with the pawn
okay
the suggestion by the engine here is to
actually take on F6 first
and then continue from this position
with an eye and maybe playing Knight E4
later maybe Rook G5 and then double
okay he doesn't exchange Knights here he
goes with Rook G5
Knight takes Knight Knight takes Knight
and C5 is still hitting
so how many are on it one two three four
and there's only three here supporting
it
but
this here is not a reliable
uh defender of the C5 Square
so there's this idea of F5 which
actually cuts out
the night gives the knighted kick and it
cuts off The Rook from seeing the C5
Square
so this is where
there starts to be a shift in the
evaluation and when you look at it
um you know when you use some reasoning
here you could kind of understand
why that is so this earlier move Rook G5
was designed to do what
try and prevent the C5 Advance well C5
is still hitting so it sort of makes
this move in a way
turns out to be a bit of a waste
C5 can still be played
from here we have D takes C5
and now
the in-between move thrown in F5 kicking
away
the Knight interfering with the Rook
seeing the C5 Square
I like the order by the way the computer
says you can maybe even go with
F5 in this position first
but there's some more you would have to
calculate as black if you're going with
F5 first and then C5
okay if you go with F5 first Knight C3
and then C5 there's this as a possible
Pawn break
but playing C5 right now this is not an
option
okay
in this game it is D takes C4
so softening up you might say White's
grip over the E5 Square
so this starts to maybe be more of a
possibility
the E5 Advance F5 first kicking the
Knight back
moving forward would be losing
diving in here losing not because of
Queen takes Knight
white wouldn't take back the queen
because
Rook takes Queen and
black is up at night
white would have Queen takes Knight in
this position to get out of that tactic
but the win here would be to Simply take
on C5 and remove the defender of the
Knight
Queen here
you have multiple wins Knight C2 Rook D5
okay can't go forward Knight gotta go
back C3 it is Rook takes C5 the position
has opened up
the centers opened up white is better
centralized white is really all in his
chips are all in here on the king side
this idea to do something along the G
file
Queen is kicked back and here we go
E5 on board
this Pawn really wasn't doing a whole
lot on
this this Square E6 you know it's
watching over F5 but do we need that we
have plenty of security over F5
you might say it's defending the king
somewhat along this diagonal but
really it really isn't a great way for
the queen to make use of that diagonal
this really is the way to go
uh strike F4 try and remove this guy
maybe get
the king
give a check on the diagonal White's
play is all in on the G file White's
trying to open up the center and open
lines for the Rooks to maybe get to the
second rank to kind of sneak in
in this kind of Direction
okay
white doubles up in the G file
and again this is only a
Blitz or a rapid game really as it comes
out to the starting time control at
least it's uh rapid for
why and black is really in Blitz mode
right in the beginning
but yeah fast time control game the
reaction here is King h8 this is
considered the second best move
but really it's in a way like the best
move when you think about it
if you don't go with King to h8 if you
instead capture here this is the best
move by the way
this would mean you'd have to calculate
the following line
and this is not at all easy to do uh
maybe maybe in the classical you get
away with this but yeah you definitely
need time to know that you're okay
finding this is an only move and after
this move finding this as an only move
working out all the details uh here
knowing that there isn't a great
discovery uh discovered check for white
all right
the best move let's just say is played
here two humans going at it
get off of the G file don't allow this
to be hitting with check now
okay
Queen F3 is played if
The Rook captures in this case black
would be able to defend this does not
hit with check there's multiple ways to
defend here Queen H7 is one
uh Queen H7
if Rook G5 black has this resource to
stop the skewer with Rook H5
okay
so this is not working the sacrifice on
G6 white still needs a few Tempe before
there's a serious threat posed to the
black king he needs moves H4 H5 the
capture before it really has Black's
attention
in the game Queen F3
he takes F4
Pawn takes F4
looks pretty ugly here double isolated
pawns but this guy is still around to
Shield the king if White had captured
with the queen
it runs into this irritating move Knight
D3 really hitting a lot of stuff
undermining possibly the Knight support
once you wipe out the B Pawn
this may seem tempting giving a check
but there's 95 and look at what might be
right around the corner talk about a
massive
Fork if the Knight gets to F3
um yeah this might seem tempting but you
could always kick the queen
away
from pinning the Knight and in fact the
queen is
basically going to be trapped in this
position after Rook d8 how do you like
that it just goes to show the
the great centralization here of the
black pieces
all in for white
the center control is what's going to
Triumph here
okay
in this game it is e takes D4
Rook d8
and here we go with H4 uh we could
probably look a little less now at the
sacrifices on G6 now that
H4 is in because this is always a
possibility Queen takes H4 and that
would immediately
influence the coordination with the
Rooks King is going to have to
go in between them or The Rook is going
to have to block so
this is no longer is it's less effective
now with the pawn on H4 one step away
from the King
okay in this game we have Rook D3
and the reply here is Queen A8
objectively best
uh funny move here I don't know if both
Players missed this or both players
maybe had calculated
uh that this wasn't maybe even going to
lead anywhere again we have to take into
account the
that this is an Armageddon white has to
try and find some variation that's going
to win
the best move in this position
objectively is can you guess which move
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
clean well not Queen there Queen is the
move Queen Aid is the move played in the
game Queen H5
is is the best move in this position
pretty flashy okay if you take the queen
there's going to be a main one that's
the idea and this I guess this variation
I'm highlighting is your little reminder
to
take some extra care whenever you move
that final Rook from your back rank this
was the first moment
it's a bit more vulnerable there isn't a
rook on d8 anymore
so is there a way to make use of the uh
these back rank weaknesses there is
Queen H5
seems like it's an
out of the blue Type move but it's there
and nearby there's this idea
there's ways to defend for black but in
any case this is objectively the best
move Queen H5 in this game Queen A8
check
Rook falls back to d8 and White's next
move here is a blunder and the
conversion here is
pretty good here for black
the best move in this position for white
is Rook to E1
saying if you take my Rook I take your
Rook we exchange in a fancy way holds
this around an even position
okay I guess in general what's What's
Happening Here the computer suggesting
this isn't going to be working so try
and
you know
centralize a rook go in that direction
but
okay in this game it's Queen G2 and
black simply goes in after this F Pawn
so I didn't mention this when this
capture happened I was pointing out it's
still shielding the king but it is now
also a whole
because of those earlier moves E5
the capture on that square the recapture
as soon as there was that recapture on
F4
now becomes a hole and black is laser
focused on it from here
Knight D3
you could do a knight comparison
the Black Knight
outranks this guy
the Ford moves are under control
and what are you doing about Knight
takes F4 can't really do anything
Queen F3 Rook C4
Queen G3
Rook takes F4
blacks now on F2
F3
one final move and white resigns
H6 this Rook is stuck
what do you do
white resigns in this position if you
capture
if the game continued and he captured on
G6 they would follow Rook takes
an H4 check ing G2 and how strong would
this Knight be on F4
well the queen has to give herself up
now for the night otherwise it's going
to be mate That's How Strong
so if you go to F2 for example
there's gonna follow Rook f
Lex next to me Rook D2 check King F1 and
Rook D1 check
King here
that's a slick mate with Queen C5
and if Knight takes Rook Queen E2 would
be me
it's not a three point night a knight on
F4 is probably worth more than four
okay
H6 find him over this Armageddon game an
interesting one I like seeing these
faster time control games White had to
go all in with this format and it didn't
simply didn't work out but very
instructive to see how the approach the
approaches here the Battle of plans the
opening up the opening up of the center
uh this was Black's way to get at the
white king first
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye